>> Welcome. Thank you for
joining, our session will begin
soon.
>> Hello, everyone, and welcome
to effective maching learning
are Cloud TPUs.  I'm delighted
to see all of you here and I'd
like to send a special welcome
to everyone on the live stream
or anyone who is watching this
as a recording later.  I'm Zak
Stone.  I'm the product manager
for TensorFlow and Cloud TPUs on
the Google Brain team
and this talk is it about
supercomputers for maching
learning that are built
around Google's custom chips
called Tensor Processing Units,
or TPUs.  We've had three
generations of Tensor Processing
Units, including the one on
the bottom that Sundar announced
in his
keynote earlier this morning but
before I get into the details
here, I just want to set the
stage for a moment and share a
little bit of context about why
this matters.  There's been a
tremendous amount of maching
learning progress over the past
several years as you've probably
already heard earlier today.  If
you look at the number of
research publications on Arxiv,
which is an open site for
sharing papers, the number of
papers is growing faster than
Moore's Law and we're up to
something like 50 new maching
learning papers every day.
This is a tremendous rate of
innovation.  A lot of it is
happening out in the open, which
is fantastic, and it's driving a
lot of new applications and real
progress across a wide range of
fields.  As you can see here in
just one domain computer vision,
there's been a tremendous
increase in accuracy on this
image net benchmark challenge
just over
the past few years rising from
the
original break through results
with Alexnet all the way to some
of the more recent models, but
these accuracy trends come at a
cost that I'll tell you about in
a minute.
First I want to help you
understand what those sort of
applications are about.  You've
heard a little bit about
diabetic
retinopathy and also these new
signals of heart health you can
get in a completely passive way
just by taking a picture of the
back of the eye.  This is real
world application that's
going to help improve people's
lives that's only possible
because of these cutting edge
models in maching learning.
You've also probably heard about
tracking illegal logging in the
rain forest.  By putting
recycled cell phones in trees
that can listen for sounds of
chain saws or other activities
and help people protect rain
forest in the central Amazon.
Now, one thing that's remain
changed
even since I was in graduate
school is
this unification across many
different application domains.
Before, it might have been some
one folks in vision had one
technique, the folks in speech
had a different technique and
the folks doing machine
translation were doing yet a
third set of techniques to go
from one language to another,
but what we've been seeing over
the past few years is this
consolidation, especially in
deep learning around these
neural networks that have
similar components even in the
details of their structure are
different.
And these mural networks are now
achieving state of the art
results across all these
different tasks.  Often these
results are at accuracies we
don't know how to achieve any
other way.
So, now, as I mentioned earlier,
this has come at a bit of a cost
which is, as these models get
more accurate, they tend to be
larger, trained on larger data
sets and that means that you
need more computation both to
train the model run it.
What I'm showing here is this
plot of
image recognition models on
Image Net, this time ranked with
accuracy on the
vertical axis and then the
number of
multiply odds which is sort of a
rough
computational cost and as you
can see, as you get to these
higher and higher accuracies,
you're actually requiring
larger and larger amounts of
computation.
So the solution to this problem,
we believe, is specialized
hardware for really driven us to
develop these multiple
generations of Tensor Processing
Units or TPUs.  Our first TPUs
have been in our data center
since 2015 and you've interacted
with these every time you've run
a search.
They're reranking the last
several hundred links to choose
what they're sending you,
they've been a part of Google
Photos and speech recognition
and many of Google's large scale
applications you use every day.
Last year, we revealed our
second generation Tensor
Processing Unit which are now in
public beta.
Anyone can sign up, any TPU
project
can start a TPU, you can follow
the link g.co/Cloudtpu to learn
more.  These aren't just for
training and inference on a
simple system, they're
really designed to be used
together in
these large supercomputers we
call TPU pods.  Here's a full
pod of the second generation
TPUs on the screen right now.
Finally, this morning, you're
getting the first glimpse of our
third generation TPUs assembled
into an even
larger TPU pod that delivers
more than  100petaflops of
compute for a single maching
learning problem.
So, I just want to emphasize
that we are
committed to making relentless
progress in this domain.  This
affects all of our products.  It
improves the lives of all of our
users and through the Cloud,
we're bringing these platforms
to you so you can train maching
learning models and
run them faster and more cost
effectively than ever before.
Just a few notes on performance,
you
can see TPU view one with 92
teraops
only doing inference then going
to the
Cloud TPU which is 180
teraflops, suddenly you have
floating points, you don't have
to worry as much.  Those are
connected together in these
systems that as I mentioned
before are
up to 11 and a half petaflops
and do training and inference.
You can slice them into smaller
pieces to do many different
problems at once.
Just a year later now we're
making this leap to about 11 and
a half petaflops to more than
100.
That's more than 8X the
performance in this new system
and that's a combination of an
entirely new chip wired together
into an even larger scale
system.
So
I hope the reason you're all
here is that you're interested
in expanding the AI Frontier.
That's what really motivates us
when we're  developing these
platforms and building
applications on top of them.
Now, I'd really like to focus on
what you can do right now with
the Cloud TPUs that are
available today.  And that
really starts with performance.
A lot of these maching learning
models
can take days or weeks to train
.  It hasn't been uncommon in
the past for it to cost
thousands of dollars just to do
one training model and we're
really interested in bringing
down these costs and making
maching learning acceleration
much more widely available.
But, when we're talking about
performance, it's important to
be very specific about what we
mean because it's quite subtle
sometimes to compare one system
to another.  First of all, in
all of our
measurements, we try to focus on
real world data, time to
accuracy, and cost.  So, let me
tell you what I mean.  When
you're training a maching
learning model and you're
processing millions of images,
it's convenient to look at how
many samples a second you're
processing as a measure of
performance.
But those samples per second
numbers don't matter unless you
ultimately get
where you need to go
, reach the correct final
accuracy.  So what we're really
looking to do is measure how
fast the wheels are spinning on
the car but also make sure that
the car gets to the right
destination and crosses the
finish line.
So, it's very important whenever
you're considering building,
buying, renting a maching
learning system to make sure
that you're asking about not
only steps per second or samples
per second, but
also the training accuracy and
the total time to accomplish the
task that you really have in
mind.
We've also put in a lot of
energy to try and make sure that
all these ML benchmarks that we
talk about are reproducible via
open source.  So, almost all the
numbers that I'm about to show
you.  Either you can reproduce
today by going to -- or they'll
be open source soon so you'll be
able to reproduce them on your
own.  You don't just have to
take my word for it.
Now, Stanford recently hosted a
competition called DAWNBench.
I've got a screen shot of the
website here.
And DAWNBench is the first
public benchmark challenge that
we've seen really measure
performance and accuracy
together which we think was
great.  There was active
participation from many
different companies and
individuals
and research groups and I'm
happy to
announce that Cloud TPUs and TPU
pods did very well across
several of the categories.
So, in the image Net training
cost
competition we had the number
one Don DAWNBench entry with a
model called AmoebaNet-D.  Now
this is a really interesting
fusion of some of the work we've
been doing with these platforms
because
AmoebaNet was an architecture
evolved from scratch on TPUs and
that model not only if you train
it longer can get to state of
the art accuracy on Image Net
but it can hit the target that
DAWNBench set of 93 percent in
just seven and a half hours for
under $50.
This really makes that kind of
state of the art performance
accessible to a much wider
audience than it's ever been
before.  Now, another model that
you may have heard of that's
frequently benchmarked is ResNet
50.  And so I just wanted to
show a quick case study of
ResNet 50 running with
TensorFlow 1.8 which is our most
recent version.  We also
submitted this to DAWNBench and
it also reaches this accuracy of
percent which is not -- this is
top five accuracy.  That's not
easy to do with ResNet.  It's
easy to fall just a little bit
short and you have to be very
careful throughout the
implementation to achieve
that high accuracy while
maintaining
this incredible performance of
more than 3,250 images per
second.
Now, this took almost nine hours
to train for 59 dollars, but if
you want to go faster, part of
the reason that we
design these systems to be
connected together is just by
changing the batch size of the
model.  No code changes, no
complicated thinking about
distributed systems.
The we can run the same thing on
half of one of these TPU pods to
hit the same level of accuracy
in just 30 minutes.
So, that's nine hours down to 30
minutes, and these are the pods
that are coming to Cloud later
this year so you'll be able to
run results like this on your
own or train on other models
with other data sets of your
own.
If you eliminate the check point
overhead which DAWNBench didn't
actually require us to measure,
that's actually just 24 un
minutes.
So, what I'd like to mention,
though,
is the field is moving extremely
fast.  Just as an example, the
third place entry for training
cost was from a nonprofit
organization called fast.AI and
that actually came in at $72 but
included some really interesting
ideas that weren't well-known.
One was this progressive scaling
up of training images that
enabled the model to move even
faster in the earlier stages of
training when it's just starting
to figure out how to complete
the task and they also used a
much more aggressive learning
rate schedule that hadn't been
widely used.
The nice thing about Cloud TPU
is it was easy for us to make
these changes in our own model
and unofficially rerun the
experiment.
And these two simple changes
take our ResNet training cost
from $59 down to just 25 with
today's on demand pricing that
you can get on Google Cloud.  So
there's an open source reference
implementation available.  We've
built this into our B15 version
of ResNet 50 and we'll have more
to say about this soon.  But
kudos to fast.AI for the great
algorithmic improvements and I'm
just delighted as a researcher,
practitioner and now a product
manager that so much of this
progress is widely shared.  So,
you might be wondering, well,
what's the next benchmark
challenge.  DAWNBench finished
recently.  Where do we go next
to compare these very different
systems, different sizes and
scales and even different model
architectures against one
another if we need to make a
decision about what to do when
you want to accomplish a goal.
Well, one new challenge that's
been released recently.  There
are a bunch of researchers from
different top Universities and
also many companies coming
together.
Trying to define a new next
generation, it's even more
challenging than DAWNBench and
covers many more problem
domains.  The first deadline is
going to be in July.  This group
is open to new collaborators,
and also planning to iterate on
the definition of the benchmark
to make sure that it really
tracks where the field is going
so I think this is going to be
really exciting later this year
and I encourage you to
participate and check it out.
And as I've mentioned before, I
just want to provide a little
bit more information about what
you can do today with Cloud TPUs
if you want to experience this
kind of performance.  We've got
this set of reference models.
I'll say more about them in a
minute
but they're right there on
GitHub/TensorFlow/TPU and we've
also got great documentation
object Cloud website.  But you
don't have to remember the links
at the top.  Just g.co/Cloud TPU
will take you where you need to
go.  Now I'd like to give you a
sense of what it's like hands on
to use these Cloud TPUs.  First
of all, one thing that's a
little different than other
accelerators is that they're
network attached.  So what that
means is you can choose a
virtual machine of any size or
shape.  You can, you know,
attach other accelerators to it,
if you want.  It can be large
but we generally start
with a very tiny VM because this
is really playing just a
coordinating role.  As few as
four cores are often enough
because all the real
computational work are happening
on the Cloud TPU.  The nice
thing about this set-up is that
Cloud TPU can be a single device
or a slice of one of those pods.
You don't have to worry about
it.  All that's handled for you.
Furthermore, you don't have to
worry about messing with
drivers.  You can just use these
machine images that we provide.
You program these Cloud TPUs
with TensorFlow.  Now,
TensorFlow is the most popular
open source framework for
maching learning, one of the top
projects on GitHub, and it's
just taken off since it was open
sourced in November of 2015.
We're now up to something like
13 million downloads all around
the world.  TensorFlow supports
many different kinds of maching
learning and has many different
components.  When you're
programming Cloud TPUs today,
you'll focus on layers,
estimators, the TF.
data fast input pipelines, and
then your code will be
transformed behind the scenes by
the XLA team to talk to the TPU.
So, estimators and layers really
provide these high-level deep
learning
abtractions for TensorFlow had a
let you do a wide variety of
models of TPUs.
Here's just a quick example of a
convolutional network.
This is how you would write it
with some estimators, what you
can see here is you just have to
make some minimal changes to map
this over to the TPU.  Changes
in the optimizer and estimator.
We're working over time to make
these changes smaller and
smaller so it would be really
convenient for you to take
throw code that runs on TPUs or
GPUs,
run it on CPUs, move back and
forth wherever you need to take
your code and run.
One important bit of advice,
though, that I'd like to just
emphasize over and over, high
performance computing is hard on
any platform and these
accelerators are so fast that
you need to really put in a lot
of energy to make sure that the
whole system is balanced and
that every part of it is
performing as well as it
possibly can.  We've done a
tremendous amount of this work
for you with these reference
models that I'm about to show
you that we've got open source
on GitHub.
For example, here are four
different categories of very
different applications that are
either supported
today or are about to be open
source for Cloud TPU.  Over in
the image recognition column
which is maybe best known we've
got AmoebaNet and ResNet 50,
also bigger
versions of it, inceptions v2,
v3, v4 but we can also do
October detection with RetinaNet
which is another one of these
models and I'll say more about
that in a minute.  Also, if
you're interested in training a
maching learning model and
deploying it at the edge on a
phone or robot or vehicle or
somewhere oles, might want to
train a smaller model with
something
like mobile net or squeeze net
and Cloud TPUs support those as
well.  But we're not limited to
image or object recognition.
TPUs can also do translation,
language modeling, sentence
analysis, question answering all
with this state of the art model
architecture called Transformer
that's very powerful and
flexible.
Turns out a version of
Transformer can also perform
fantastic speech recognition and
we've just recently open
sourced an example of
-- part of the Tensor to Tensor
network.  I'll tell you more
about that in a minute.  And
finally over in the image
generation category, we've got
the image
Transformer and also DC gan so
we've really got a huge range of
applications that are not only
possible to make work on the
Cloud TPU but they're working
today with open source code that
you can just download.
It's a really easy way to get
started.  So, for those of you
who aren't as familiar with this
domain, image classification is
often taking these small images
like this one and mapping that
to a category like lion whereas
object detection is taking
larger images and looking for
many different objects in many
different places in the image.
The cool thing about our
RetinaNet implementation is it
lets you process
quite large images, 896 by 896,
trains
to a very interesting accuracy,
in just six hours for $40.
Machine translation gets to very
close
to state of the art, again, in
just 6.2 hours for $41.  And
these results are changing all
the time as we continue to
optimize the platform, the
implementations and new
research comes out, much of
which at Google is conducted on
these TPUs.
Now, language modeling, you're
trying to predict the next word.
This is an important component
of applications like smart
reply.  And again, you take the
language
modeling, the LM1B, the 1
billion word
data set and train to a state of
the art
per plexity of 28 in 74 hours
for under
$500, that has the latest
results for all these speech
recognition models.
For speech recognition we've got
this
ASR Transformer which is
training on LibriSpeech again to
a really interesting error age.
This is to just train your own
near state of the art speech
recognition model from scratch
in whatever language or accent
you care about and you can get
to a reasonable accuracy for
under 100 dollars.
Finally, question answering
here, with QANet, this is just
the fast version we used to win
the question/answer competition
for DAWNBench but there's a
question and answer that takes a
big chunk of text and then
presents a
question that you can infer from
some fact so this maching
learning model is looking at
this whole about a paragraph
of unstructured text, reading
the text, getting its answer.
It's really interesting and all
this is possible on this
flexible, new, powerful platform
from maching learning.
I forgot I was going to tell you
a little bit more about image
generation.  The metrics here is
actually bits per dimension and
lower is better.
State of the art is 2.92 but
under three is really good and
you can get under three on this
metric in 30 hours for under
$200 if you're interested in
exploring the state of the
art, cutting edge image
generation examples, all those
images on the right were
generated from scratch just
dreaming on the basis of a
training set
using this image Transformer
model
so, again, why start with a
reference model instead of just
opening a code editor and
starting from scratch.  He's
reference models are high
performance, they're open
source, haircut they're cutting
edge.
Often collecting, we
continuously test them for
performance and accuracy which
means you don't have to worry
that some subtle change in
TensorFlow or some other part of
the stack might reduce the
accuracy without you realizing
it.  You can get up and running
really quickly and then modify
as needed because you have the
code, it's yours on your
infrastructure and you can train
and run on your own data.
But, you're perfectly welcome to
do it the hard way.  We have
lots of detailed technical
advice in our troubleshooting
guide and
you know,
I'm not kidding that high
performance computing is hard
and any part of the
system can become a bottle neck
but we totally encourage you to
take the high level layers in
API and build new models and let
us know, what works for you?
Just to give you a little bit of
a sense of what makes high
performance computing so tricky,
you know, if you're training
with slower hardware, you might
find that you can overlap your
input processing with your
training time and
so
your accelerators are always
saturated but when the
accelerators get faster
what you find as subtle is that
you're accelerating on the -- so
fortunately, we've provided a
bunch of tools that are
connected into TensorBoard which
is this great visualization
framework associated
with TensorFlow to help you
debug your performance,
understand what's going on,
here I'm showing steps per
second and loss but with you
actually have this very detailed
profiler that lets you go in and
get ops statistics on what's
going on in your model and we
even have
high level recommendations.  I
don't know if you can read but
it's telling you, in this case,
your model is not input bound so
you should spend more time on
steps.  In other cases, it will
tell you, you're blocked on
input.  You need a faster
pipeline.  So, we're really
doing our best to present these
tools for experts and all
this documentation for experts
but also to make it really easy
to get started with these
reference models across this
huge range of applications.
Now, those of you who are used
to training and modeling maching
learning applications, you might
wonder, well, why should I jump
to the Cloud.
That seems like a different
platform how do I think about
that?  The nice thing about
training in the Cloud is you get
all this infrastructure that you
can mix and match to get what
you need like those custom VMs I
was telling you about earlier.
You can scale up and down
quickly.  You don't need to
build hardware, maybe scale a
machine yourself, wait months
for hardware to arrive.  You can
sign on today.  Scale up to
hundreds of TPUs if you wish.
There's great security all
throughout Google Cloud.  Google
is state of the art for
enterprises that want cutting
edge
maching learning
hardware Andrew able to reduce
your capital expenditure.  You
can train one model for 50 bucks
and then turn the Cloud TPU off
and you're not paying for it
anymore, which is great.
So just a few words from two of
our customers.
Two Sigma is a financial firm
and Lyft, both of them have had
great experience using Cloud
TPUs to focus on the models
instead of worrying about
these distributed clusters of
other
hardwares and taking month
models that used to train for
days down to hours and with
these larger and larger pods,
we're
really trying to drive that to
minutes.
So, let's go under the hood and
talk in more detail about what's
going on in the current
generation of Cloud TPU.  So,
first of all, the clue actually
includes a host with this
accelerator
all behind the scenes connected
via PCI.  Each Cloud TPU device
has these four chips under the
heat syncs here and I'm going to
zoom in on one of them.  If you
look at the Cloud TPU chip
layout, you'll see that it's
broken down into two cores that
look like this.  Now, these
cores are really built around
the systolic array which is an
old idea but it's newly relevant
in this age of maching learning
when so many of the computations
really look like gigantic matrix
multipliers.
But we've also got a vector unit
and scalar unit.  In this case,
it was eight gigabytes of high
memory per core.  The new
actually doubles the memory per
chip which is going to let you
train
even larger and more capable
models.
Focusing in on this matrix unit,
this systolic array, one thing
that's really interesting is
we're doing it with a new
floating format called B float
16.  I'll say more about that in
a minute but it really gives us
this great performance for
maching learning without a
meaningful cost in accuracy.
We're still accumulating in
float 32, though.
So most of you are probably
familiar with 32 bit floating
point.
As you can see here, the orange
bits are all devoted to
measuring these fine differences
between numbers which is really
important if you're doing high
performance computing, detailed
simulations, that kind of thing.
But in maching learning it turns
out that the range is more
important and these maching
learning models are not super
sensitive to these fine diverses
by and large.
So the IEEE start for a 16-bit
floating points really cuts down
the range of numbers that you
can express.  One thing we're
finding with
TensorFlow is if you're training
with
half precision IEEE like this
you really have to pay attention
on a model by model basis to
make sure all of your numbers
stay in the right range and
don't overflow and those
techniques are difficult to
apply in general across a wide
range of models.
With bfloat16, though, what
we've done
instead is saved more bits
fortuneit which supports the
range and it's supported
seamlessly by our Cloud TPU
hardware so those ResNet 50
result I was
talking about earlier were
achieved with bfloat16 and we're
still achieving that 95 percent
accuracy with minimal effort and
special casing on a model by
model basis.
So, here I'll show a brief
animation of the systolic array.
In this slide it's only three by
three
but imagine this is 128 by 128
to get a sense of how different
this is from an ordinary central
processing unit and how much
parallelism there is which is
where we're getting this
fantastic performance.  So, here
you have data streaming in and
what's happening as the systole
eggic array sort of beats on
every step is you're getting
great reuse of these
intermediate rums as the data is
flowing through the systolic
array and generating the output.
So, this is super high flewput
for flew
throughput and also does a great
job of taking high level
mathematical expressions and
then mapping them down into this
coordinated dance of low level
operations that gives us this
tremendous amount of speed.
So, where do we go from here?
Well first of all, I really want
to
emphasize something I haven't
called out explicitly about
scaling up.
I think the days of single
systems are irrelevant.  They're
over.
Because what you care about
ultimately
is how fast you get to your
result, right?  And so what
we're trying to do with these
Cloud TPUs and making them
widely
available in the Cloud is giving
you just a dial that you can
turn where you do your
prototyping on an inexpensive
single device and then you
increase the batch size without
doing any other code changes and
suddenly your training time is
going down from hours to
minutes.
And so, I'll show you two, you
know, real measurements from our
TPU systems in house here to
give you a sense of how that's
possible.  First of all, what
I'm demonstrating here if you
look at these TPU devices so the
second generation TPU pod has 64
of these boards in it, and you
can see
linear scaling of images per
second up to the right herement
as you know, remember, if you
hear images per second,
it's like, but wait, had a about
the accuracy?
You can check our DAWNBench
result.
That also confirms we can get
the high accuracy with this
scaleout but what you can see is
our interconnecting this pod is
so fast that you don't have to
struggle the way you would with
mixing and matching hardware on
your own, whether on premise or
in the Cloud.  You can just turn
this dial with no code changes
and benefit from this super fast
proprietary network.
But, there's a more subtle point
here that's a mathematical
issue, which is, until recently
it hasn't been clear how to take
these maching learning models
and increase the batch size
which is how
many of these images you're
processing simultaneously sort
of in each step while you're
training.  There's been a huge
amount of research energy on
this recently and there have
been a lot of break throughs
where we're now able to train
effectively on much larger batch
sizes from ever before.  That's
great news for scaling up with
these TPU pods.  Let me help you
interpret this graph.
What you see on the horizontal
axis here is time and what you
see on the vertical axis is
accuracy.  And so you might
imagine your first
implementation on your Cloud TPU
thattor
renting today gets to, let's
say, 76
percent accuracy on ResNet 50
and that takes a certain amount
of time.  That's that orange
curve out there.  But with no
code changes, just by changing
the batch size in the right way
with the models that we've
already open
sourced you can pull that time
in as you're using larger and
larger sections of the pod until
you get down to these 30 minute
results or possibly even better.
So, we think this is an
extremely promising research
direction and we're doing our
best in all these reference
implementations to make sure
that it's immediately accessible
to you so once these pods become
more widely available in Cloud,
then you'll be able to just
transparently benefit from this
large batch training.
I'd love to live in a world
where you
can use an exoflop for a minute
and then let it go while
somebody else is using it and
swap back and forth.
Now, here's another view of the
full TPU v3 pod that Sundar
showed you this
morning and we are doing
everything that we can to push
the boundaries of performance,
and that's what's really
led us to liquid cool this pod
in comparison to everything
we've done previously that's air
cooled.  If you want a cool,
close-up view, there it is.  A
close-up view of just one of the
boards in that pod, it looks
sort of like this and you can
see the tubing.
Now those plates are on each one
of these next generation TPU v3
processors.  So we're going to
go to the largest batch sizes we
can, we're  publishing
all this research that we're
doing.  We're open sourcing as
much as it as we can on these
Cloud TPU platforms that you can
access today.
And so we're really excited in
going with you into this
exciting AI Frontier.  You can
get started right now with
these high performance reference
models
and tutorials and please reach
out to us.  Let us know.  We'd
be really interested in hearing
your feedback on the Cloud TPU
platform of today.  We'd love to
know where you would like it to
go.
We hope you enjoy all these
across image generation, and
speech recognition.  Image
translation.  And I'd be happy
to take some of your questions
offline after the talk.
So, thank you very much for
listening.  I've included some
links here.  Thanks again.
(Session was concluded at 4:34
PM CT)
***
This text, document, or file is
based on live transcription.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART), captioning,
and/or live transcription are
provided in order to facilitate
communication
accessibility and may not be a
totally verbatim record of the
proceedings.  This text,
document, or file is not to be
distributed or used in any way
that may violate copyright law.
***
RAW FILE
GOOGLE I/O 2018
MOUNTAIN VIEW, CALIFORNIA
MAY 8, 2018
STAGE 8
3:00 PM
ANDROID VITALS:  VITALS: DEBUG
APP
PERFORMANCE AND REAP REWARDS
TB8E1C
Services Provided By:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO 80132
1 877 825 5234
+001 719 481 9835
www.captionfirst.com
***
This text, document, or file is
based on live transcription.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART), captioning,
and/or live transcription are
provided in order to facilitate
communication
accessibility and may not be a
totally verbatim record of the
proceedings.  This text,
document, or file is not to be
distributed or used in any way
that may violate copyright law.
***
GOOGLE I/O 2018
STAGE 8
3:00 PM
LADY VITALS: DEBUG APP
PERFORMANCE AND
REAP REWARDS
M
ANDROID VITALS: DEBUG APP
PERFORMANCE AND REAP REWARDS
TB8E1C
>> Welcome. Thank you for
joining.  Our session will begin
soon.
>> Good afternoon, everybody.
And welcome.  Today's session is
all about app performance.
My name is Joel Newman and I'm a
product specialist on Google
Play business development team.
In that capacity, I've worked
with Android developers of all
shapes and sizes helping them to
leverage the tools
available and the
Google Play Console to build
successful apps and businesses.
Now I'm going to kick off with a
quick
reminder of how vital
performance is.  Then my
colleague, Fergus, product
manager for Android Vitals will
join me on stage to talk about
some of the ways we're enhancing
the platform to make it easier
to understand and action your
performance information.
Then, my colleague B
Wojtek from our development team
will come on stage.  Finally,
we'll wrap things up by talking
about some of the resources
available within the Play
Console itself and beyond to
improve your performance, and if
we have time, we'll try to do a
brief Q&A.
Now, first, I think it's
important to remind ourselves of
why performance is important.
Now, I think this is intuitive,
right?
We as users, nobody wants to
deal with
an app that crashes frequent
frequently
or freezes or is janky but at
Google we have data that drives
home just how important
performance is.  We did an
analysis of all the reviews on
the play store over the past
year and found that when using a
one star review, over 40 percent
of the time users cited negative
performance indicators like
stability and bugs.  In fact,
this was the number one cited
issue within one star review.
Now, on the flip side when using
five star reviews, over 70
percent of the users mentioned
positive performance indicators,
things like speed, design, and
usability.  Now, why is this
important?
Now, not only are ratings and
reviews a direct indicator of
customer satisfaction and not
only do they figure heavily in
the search algorithm, but
ratings and reviews correlate
strongly with downstream
business APIs.
Things like engagement,
retention, and
monetization.  A great example
comes from this study.  We did
an analysis of all the games in
Google Play and we compared
those with the lowest versus the
highest crash rate and we found
apps with the lower crash rate
saw almost two and a half
minutes
more of game play per day and
this was even a bigger trend
when we looked at A and Rs which
are more frequently looked over.
We found that users spent almost
three more minutes per day in
the more stable apps.
Now, this may not sound like a
ton of time but when you look at
this over a yearly basis, this
would translate into 18 hours of
additional game play per user
for games that are played on a
taillie basis.  -- daily basis.
Now, another reason why
performance is
incredibly important is it's
becoming an increasingly
important
signal if Google Play.
We're committed to only the
highest
quality content to our users,
taking into account performance
indicators
particularly those related to
stability and battery
consumption in both our play
store algorithm as well as our
algorithmically generated
recommendations.  In addition to
that, performance signals factor
heavily into our
decisions around our editorially
curated content.  This includes
our featured new and updated
apps collection as well as
editor's choice and coveted
Google Play awards and Android
excellence.  If you want your
app business to succeed, your
app needs to be discovered.
And technical performance is an
increasing part of that
discovery within the play store.
Now, it's
because of that increasing
importance of performance that
we launched Android Vitals.
This is an initiative by Google
to improve the stability and
performance of
Android devices by circulating
to developers in an easily
understandable
and readily accessible way the
most important performance
metrics in battery, stability,
and rendering.  This comes from
over 100 million users who have
opted into to share the data
with Google and with you, our
developer partners.
And since the program's launch a
year ago, it's been an
incredible success.
We have over 100,000 developers
including some of the biggest
names on Android platform
regularly engaging with
the Vitals Console to understand
their
performance issue and create
fixes.  Now it's because of this
incredible engagement that we've
seen some really nice games at
an ecosystem.
When we compare reviews in the
Play Store today versus a year
ago when we launched Vitals we
see a really nice uptick in
those people leaving reviews
talking about things like speed,
design, and usability.  But
perhaps more importantly, when
we look at people using one star
reviews, we've seen almost a 20
percent decrease in the number
of people talking about
things like stability and bugs
and battery consumption and
that's only possible because of
the incredible work that you
have done as a developer
community to up the quality of
Android apps.
And for those of you who are new
to the platform, it's really
important that you keep pace
with the rest of the developer
community who is helping us move
in a positive performance
direction.  Now, I think these
gains at an ecosystem level are
interesting, you might wonder as
a developer, yeah, but how does
that really matter to me some
well I want to show case a
couple of examples of where
individual developers
have seen incredible gains
because of Android Vitals.
One of my favorite case studies
is Starbucks.
Now, Starbucks is obviously an
incredibly popular app.  They
have over 15 million downloads
on the Google Play Store.  They
started using Android Vitals in
December, admittedly several
months after the launch of the
program.  When they started
using Android Vitals they were
alerted to A and R issues that
were not even on their radar and
they
were able to use the reporting
in the Console to identify
underlying causes of ANRs caused
by a third party library.  They
removed that third party library
and saw a 70 percent reduction
in ANR within a week.  They saw
a similar and actually better
experience with crash rate.
Because Android Vitals is a
platform tool it's able to
detect crashes that
were not detected by Starbucks'
third party crash STK.  Because
they were happening before
Starbucks' third party crash STK
had even initiated.  They war
able to identify underlying
cause, push a fix and saw an 85
percent reduction in crash rate
within a week.  These are
impressive stats.
Now, it's worth calling out that
Vitals, and this is a common
misconception, is not just for
apps.  It's equally relevant for
games.
A great example comes from
Kaloo, developers of the super
popular subway surfers app which
was actually the first
game to pass the 1 billion
install mark on Google Play.
Which subway surfers started
using Android Vitals, they
discovered a 70 percent increase
in ANR rate, used the reports to
identify the cause, pushed a
fix and saw a reduction of their
ANR rate from 2.5 to below .1
percent, a 95 percent reduction.
But I think what's worth calling
out here is what we found
afterwards.
So, we did an analysis to Google
Play, what was the change in
engagement of the app before and
after the fix.
We saw really subsequent gains
in both daily app users and
subsequent users across the
board.
Now, these are just two examples
of developers who have been able
to leverage the platform to see
really significant gains both at
a performance and business
level.
Now, I'm going to invite up
Fergus, product manager for
Vitals who is going to talk
about some of the ways we're
enhancing the platform to make
it even more powerful for
developers.
(applause)
>> FERGUS HURLEY: Great job.
Hey, everyone.
I'm Fergus Hurley, product
manager for Android Vitals.
It's been incredible to see
improvements that app developers
like yourself have made and the
results.  It's also been
incredible to get all the
feedback from you as to how we
could improve Android Vitals.
I'm really excited to show with
you the new features we have
available today as a result of
your feedback, so thank you so
much.
Last year, when we announced
Android Vitals as Joel
mentioned, we launched three
performance areas.  Battery,
stability, and rendering.
Today, we're announcing two new
areas.  Start-up time and
permissions.
Battery is probably the most
important performance area to
focus on.  This is where you
should not unnecessarily use its
CPU or radios on
the device which drains user's
batteries which means they can't
use your app as long.  Stability
is all about building a robust
and reliable application so that
users are using your application
without
freezes or crashes and rendering
is all about building a fast and
responsive application that's
silky smooth and doesn't lag or
stall on users.
With start-up time, we're
enabling you to be able to
provide a quick launching
application to users no matter
what state your app has been in.
There's three different metrics
we have here and I'm going to go
through each one.
So, first, we have slow cold
start.
Slow here is defined as five
seconds or more and cold start
is when your app has not been
launched in a while and is going
from actively launched to
heavily running and the app is
not in memory.
Slow warm start is where it
takes two
seconds or more for your app to
go in actively launch to
actively running where where you
are app is in memory.
Final start time metric we have
is slow hot start.
Where your app goes from
unrestart to
activity running and takes
longer than 1.5 seconds where
your app and activity is in
memory.
Another new performance area we
have is permissions.  This is
where we want to help you be
able to only request permissions
that users think are required
for the core value of your
application to be provided
to them and if they don't think
so then
provide them justification why
you think they should actually
provide that information.  When
we ask users, what are the
reasons that you deny
permissions for applications,
what we find is that the vast
majority of them just think that
the app doesn't need those
permissions so really providing
a justification is
critical for you to get users to
be able to give you the
permission you need to be able
to offer the best functionality
possible in your application.
In the details view for
permissions we provide a
breakdown by permission group so
maybe one of your permissions
users think your app does need
and you get a high percentage of
acceptance for that one and then
another one, users don't think
you need and you get a high
denial rate for that one.  And
maybe you don't need that
permission in the first place,
so maybe you should rethink it.
Or maybe you just need to
explain to users why your app
does need that permission.
We have many other breakdowns
across
the
Vitals product.  For most, we
break it down.
For wake locks and  wake-ups, we
provide by tag, ANR, ANR type
and ANR name.
We also provide the clusters
view for grouping your ANRs
together so you can be able to
see which ones are similar
and be able to debug those
clusters.
For crashes, we also provide
When I've been building apps at
Google
and prior to Google, one of the
things I struggled with most is
being able to understand, how do
I compare?  Who also struggles
with understanding if their app
is performing well compared to
other apps?  Okay.
Lots of people share the same
struggle
.  We are now going to announce
benchmarks in the play counsel.
This enables you to be able to
see
that for start time you can see
board times are much faster.
We also provide the 25th, 50th,
and 75th percentile breakdown
for each of the category level
benchmarks.  We'll default to
the category you list yourself
in the floor but you can select
any other category that you want
to be able to compare yourself
with in case
you don't think your app is as
relative to that category.
On the details page for every
vital, we
show you this breakdown for the
category benchmark and then you
can be able to
also see what exact you are
relative to
other apps in that category.
On the redesigned Android vials
page we show you each metric,
what your percent of use
impacted in the last 30 days,
what was the percent impacted in
the previous 30 days, and we
show you the benchmark
comparison.
This enables you to quickly see,
which one of these performance
areas should I
look into and what specific
metric might require more
attention.  You can see here on
the list, if you're on the 12
percent, that's probably one you
want to investigate.
The weather channel has been
early
access partner for these
features that we're showing
today for the past couple of
weeks and one of the pieces is
it's
been really great for them to be
able to use category-level
benchmarks to make the case
within their company as to why
they should invest in
performance
because they can show how they
stack up versus competing apps.
I hope you're able to use
similar data to be able to make
the case within your company.
If you want to learn more about
benchmarks, we have a session
tomorrow at 9:30 AM.  Although
all Android Vitals should be
viewed as ways to be able to
enhance the
experience of your application,
some Vitals are more important
to offering the best user
experience possible.
So, that's why we're putting
this feature at the top of the
Android Vitals overview page
which is core Vitals.  These are
the Vitals that you should pay
most attention to.
These are the ones that will
impact your promotability and
ranking in the store along with
many other signals but we should
really pay attention to these
signals.
You'll see the list of the
Vitals.  Here we have initial
four, excessive wake-ups, where
you have ten wake-ups happening
per hour, ANR rates, where you
have a user experience the app
not responding for five seconds
or more in the day, and a crash
rate, where they have one crash
in a day.
If you're in the bottom 25
percent for
any of these bad, core Vitals,
then you'll be flagged as having
a bad behavior.
This is where you'll see
the vital and when you click on
the vital you'll be able to go
into the view and see which STK
is exhibiting that information
and we provided you that
information to help you debug
that issue.
One other major request we've
had over the past year is to get
alerted when there is an issue
that's IPed with your Vitals so
we're really happy to announce
anomaly detection.  So, this is
where you'll get flagged with an
alert at the top of your Android
Vitals section,
and crash clusters to let you
know what is the issue you have,
you can click on that tile to be
able to go in and see the
details.  You can also be able
to sign up to get email alerts
when one of these anomalies is
detected and when you get one of
those emails, there's a link
directly to the issue so you can
be able to investigate, okay,
when did this issue
occur and for how long did it
happen
.  The Big Fish games team that
have built many games have found
great
results with using these tools
over the past couple of months
and have reduced their crash
rate by 45 percent for one
of their top games
.  With that, I will introduce
Wojtek.
>> WOJTEK KALICINSKI: Hi,
everyone.  My name is Wojtek.
Today, I want to talk about how
you can fix some of these core
Vitals that Fergus mentioned in
your app, in your code.  First,
I want to start with the
stability.  Let's talk a little
bit about ANRs.  So, we keep
saying this acronym, right,
ANRs, but what are they, really?
So ANRs, in other words,
application not responding
events.
Now, this happens whenever in
your app some long running
operation locks your main
thread.  Now, the main thread is
responsible for things like
responding to user
events such as taps or redrawing
the UI
for every frame so if we drop
it, if the main thread cannot do
that in a timely manner, the app
will just seem frozen and then
after a few seconds the system
will notice that and will pop up
this annoying dialogue that lets
the user actually close the app.
As developers, we really don't
want that to happen.  So, what
are some common causes of ANRs?
Like, what kind of operations
can block our main thread?
Well, probably the most common
ones are network and disk
operations, also called I/O.
Networks are congested, remote
servers are slow.  So can be
your flash drives or the file
system can be busy with other
operations so as developers, we
should
never, ever do disk operations
on the main thread.
But, you know, we just prepare
code examples that it's not
always easy to do the right
thing.
Even though you all probably
agree we can still make
mistakes.  So here, for example,
even though my activity, I
decided, I'm just going to
prepare this to use later.  I'm
just going to create and not do
anything with it right now.  And
then somewhere else in my app
probably on a background thread
I will
actually get some information
like a string or whatever.  And
I thought, okay, that's good.
I will not be doing disk
operations on a main thread.
What I didn't realize, though,
is that the implementation of
preferences on Android actually
eagerly reads data from this the
moment you create them.  So,
that's actually the line of code
that does disk access so I was
wrong.  It's not always obvious.
And let me show you another even
trickier example.
So, here, I'm doing some
hypothetical network operations
in my app.
So, let's say I want to check if
my content has URL.  And then I
say I want to open connection to
that URL.  I'm going to save the
headers to some
variable for later use
.  So, how do I -- creates the
connection and actually blocks
my thread, or is it the last one
where I actually request to read
bytes of data to actually read
them into my application?  Or is
it something else?
Well, it's not obvious.
Actually, in this example, this
line
of code will perform a network
operation.  Like the first time
I'm trying to access headers,
only then will the connection be
open and the first bytes be
read.  So, as a developer,
again, I failed.  I didn't know
which operation does the network
access.
But fun fact, on an even older
Android version this line, just
creating, just checking if two
URLs are equal can
perform network operations.
Okay. So why am I showing you
all this?  Because I want to
since you that just as
developers, we cannot know
everything.
You will use libraries that
you're not familiar with or
other APIs.  That's why I
suggest you use trick mode.
Now, strict mode existed on
Android for a very long time.
It's pretty easy to set up.  You
just tell strict mode, I want
you to detect all disk
operations in my application on
this thread and I also want you
to detect network operations,
and then you tell strict mode
what you want the result to be.
So, first of all,
of course we want to see it in
logs so we can debug later but
logs can be easy to miss.
So for my debug, I'm actually
going to say penalty death which
will actually crash my app
whenever I do the wrong thing.
Now, like I said, you don't want
to do
any of that in your production
release builds because you don't
want your useer's app to crash.
So I go back, run my app that I
just showed you, look at my log,
because my app crashed.  And I
see the exact cause and I can go
and debug that so I can see
there was a strict mode disk
read error.  I can see it's the
default preferences that I did
on my activity create.  So,
great, this lets me actually go
and fix that.  Okay.
So, we covered network and disk
operations and how to catch
them.  But, you know, sometimes
you don't even need to hit
remote servers or disk to cause
a long running operation.  All
it takes is literally just
calculating something for for a
long
time time, doing a very long
loop and something like that.
So, here in this example, this
is a
sample sudoku game and how it
works is
when the use r opens the app,
the Sudoku board is actually
generated from memory.  It's not
read from disk.  It's not pulled
down from a server somewhere.
There's actually a pretty long
complex calculation happening to
show that first board to the
users so they can play it.  So,
it's just one code, generate
board.  And as you can see on a
slow device, this could cause an
ANR because I'm doing that on
the main thread.  So, first of
all, how am I supposed to know
as a developer that this call
generate board can be long.
Well, I really suggest that you
use Android profiler regularly.
If you ever suspect there is any
performance problem in your app.
So, here, for example, I took a
CPU trace of the method generate
board and
the profiler and I can
immediately see that it's a
complex recursive call that
takes a long, long time to
finish.  So, now I know I should
not be running it on the main
thread.  Oh, and by the way,
there's a new thing in the
Android profiler that we just
released in the cannery today,
now you can debug and profile
your app at start-up time so
that's pretty handy.
Okay. So going back to our
problem with our generate board
call, what can I do with it.
So, strict mode has this method
of
telling it that a call can be
slow
.  And now, whoever else uses
code and
uses strict mode, if they also
tag the custom slow call thread
policy, again, they will get
notified.  Their app will clash,
they will get the log and they
will know to never call that
generate board method on the
main thread.
All right, so what are some
other causes of ANRs?  Be
careful if you're doing any kind
of interprocess communication
and expect a result.  Don't do
it synchronously on the main
thread.  If you're calling some
other application, if that you
will is leading your process,
you basically don't control what
happens on the other side.
I p, C goes through layers of
the
operating system, the other
process can access network and
disk to service your
request so just remember to do
it on the background thread.
The next thing is multithreader
programming and that's a really,
really difficult  topic.  Like,
we could talk, have a whole
other session about this.  But
if you ever find yourselves
touching, you know, low level
primitives such as log
synchronization, eventually,
there's a high chance you'll
create' deadlock in your
application or hit some other
problem that blocks your main
thread and these are very tricky
to debug.  However, Android
Vitals does give you some
information that will help you
debug these kinds of problems.
So, if you open any ANR in the
Vitals Console, we actually
provide you with the trace files
pulled from the devices
that suffered from these ANRs so
you can look at thread states
and see if they were blocked
waiting on any resource to
become available and we even
highlight the problems that we
think might be happening in this
trace.  Okay. And then the last
thing I want to mention as a
cause of ANRs is slow broadcast
receiver handling.  Now, not
every developer realizes that if
you set a broadcast receiver in
your Android manifest and then
it gets cold that the on receive
method actually happens in the
main thread and you're not
supposed to perform any long
running operations in it and
there's a timeout, about ten
seconds that the system will
allow this method to run and
then it will kill your process.
So sometimes, though, whenever
you are
using a broadcast receiver maybe
to show a notification to the
user, maybe you still need a
little piece of data maybe from
the disk, like reading some name
or profile picture to show a
notification.  So, you actually
need to do that disk access.
So, what can you do in this
case?
Now, broadcast receivers have
this method called go asynch.
Basically a way to tell the
broadcast receiver from the --
that you need to do some longer
running operation and then you
spin up a separate thread
yourself.  You do the operation
and then remember to code finish
when you're done.  If you don't
do that, the system will still
realize that you're blocking and
might potentially kill your app.
And remember, don't treat this
as some kind of long running
service.  This is not the case
for broadcast receivers and the
reasonable time limit still
applies so you should literally
just grab the things you need
and the separate thread and
finish as soon as possible.
Okay. Let's talk a little bit
about caches of
and you know, it's really
difficult to
give general advice on how to
avoid crashes in a setting like
this because every app will be
different, every crash will be
different.  However, I think I
can give you some advice that
might be helpful.
So, for years as an Android
developer, I've seen a code or
my code from other people start
very simple.  And we release
something, and then
things start crashing on user's
devices so we add all these
safety measures like checking
for nulls everywhere and
checking for activity life
cycles and then if that fails we
just wrap everything in a
tricatch and just hope that this
problem doesn't hit too many
users.  But, that's not the
greatest solution, right?  It
doesn't actually solve the
underlying problem.
That's why my first piece of
advice to
you is to use readily available
libraries that solve problems
that you as developers face.
Now, some of the most difficult
parts
of Android, we heard about it
from you the developers is
handling life cycles.
That's why last year, released
some of the architecture
components such as life cycle,
view model for handling that.
Also, these ruined and page
components for loading data into
your application, into your UI.
This year, at I/O, we're
announcing two new components as
part of the Android jetpack
initiative.
This is navigation for handling
all
kinds
.  Okay. The second thing I want
to mention when talking about
crashes is Kotlin.
Last year, we announced Kotlin
as a fir class language for
Android developers.  Before I
say any more, I know it's not a
silver bullets.  It will not
solve all the crashes in your
application.  However, it can
save you for some common classes
of errors that you might
otherwise hit if you build your
apps with just Java.  Some of
the other night things about
Kotlin is that it's highly
interoperable with existing Java
code so you don't have to go all
in and transformed all your apps
into Kotlin.  You can start
slowly adding it into your
applications and see if it helps
you.
Actually, the developers love
Kotlin
and we are seeing a steady
uptake in usage.  So, if you
haven't tried yet, it's fully
supported by us and it's free to
use in your applications.
The last thing I want to talk
about is private and hidden
APIs.  Now, we offer an STK to
developers
that's backed by documentation
public interfaces that you can
use.  The developers that exist
on devices, they were never
intended for you to use.  That's
not because we don't like you
as developers, we don't want you
to do nice things.
It's just that these APIs aren't
ready to lose.  They might be
implementation details
on a certain device.
We might even remind you -- the
thing is, you should
never use private or hidden API
in your apps.
But in order to enforce that and
to actually help you make your
apps crash
less
means you have to start using
private APIs.
We did a similar thing with the
NTK
where we said you can no longer
access libraries that exist in
the system if they're not
exposed by APIs.
So, please, if you can migrate
from private APIs to public
APIs, they are documented,
guaranteed to work, to make
their apps safer.
So, let's talk about wake locks.
It's an API that lets you keep
the device from entering into a
deep sleep, from conserving the
barrier.  A stuck wake lock is
when you use the API and because
of a bug or because you forgot,
you acquire a wake lock but you
never release it so it just
keeps the CPU running and it
keeps draining the battery.
So, what's the best way to avoid
having a stuck wake lock in your
application.  You can't have one
if you don't use wake locks.
That's cultural the same thing.
Also, in modern Android
development, there's rarely a
situation when you have to use a
wake lock.  If we think about
activities, so
whenever the user is actually
using your app and for some
reason you want to keep the
screen on, instead of setting a
wake lock automatically, just
use a flag in the window that
will tell the system to keep the
screen on.  For scheduled
services, if you schedule them
as jobs instead of having
your custom free running
services, the job scheduler will
hold the wake lock for you so
again, you don't have to do that
yourselves.
Similarly, with alarm manager,
if you use it to schedule an
alarm and a broadcast receiver,
there will be a wake lock held
for you for the duration of
unreceive.
So if you don't use wake locks,
you
don't need.  So if you must use
a wake long, remember to always
choose a partial wake
lock, all the other wake locks
are
dedicated on your Android
servers and then always set a
timeout value so that in case
you use it, the system will
clean up the wake lock for you
after the timeout expires.
Remember to give a static
descriptive
tag without any counters or even
worse, private sensitive
information.  That way, we can
surface the name of the wake log
and the Android Vitals for you
for easier debugging.
And then remember to always call
defensively and assume things
can go wrong
next I want to talk about
excessive wake-ups.  I think the
biggest cause is specifically
the wake-up types of alarms.
Now, let me give you the 3Rs of
alarm manager.
Remove calls to wake-up alarms
if possible.  Reduce the
frequency if you have to use
them for some reason, and if you
can, replace your alarms with
other APIs
such as If firebase Cloud
messaging whenever the wake-up
has to happen for something on
your server and you can send it
as a push message.  Or use one
of the job scheduling APIs such
as the newly announced work
manager
or even job scheduler or sync
manager.  You know, with
intelligent job scheduling, you
get a lot of things for free
such as automatic back-up and
retry.  If your job fails for
any reason, you get criteria
based scheduling so you can
only wake the device when it has
network or is charging so you
don't run your code
unnecessarily.  You get those
and standby compliance and like
I mentioned before, even
automatic wakelock handling.
And there's a whole session
about background processing and
a work manager API where you can
learn more about this today.
So, you mentioned the Android
profiler before.  And I'm happy
to say that today in Android
Studio, we're also announcing
the new energy profiler so you
can debug any kinds of problems
with wake lock if you use them
in your app and also see
detailed information about
alarms and jobs scheduled in
your application.
If you're interested to hear
more about the profiler, please
go to the session tomorrow.  And
with that, let me invite Fergus
back on stage to talk to you
about what more you can do to
improve quality of your apps.
Thanks.
(applause)
>> FERGUS HURLEY: Great.
So, we've covered a lot about
what's available in Android
Vitals and the Play Console.
I'm just going to quickly go
through some of the other tools
you can be able to use to be
able to improve the performance
of your application.  All of
Android Vitals is based on data
that's collected from users'
devices, so, these are users
that are actually being affected
by the issue itself.  We would
love for users not to actually
be impacted by any of these
issues at all so we'd encourage
you to
do more prelaunch testing of
your applications to find
issues.
There's a session on this
Thursday at 9:30, I encourage
you to attend that one.
Over the past couple of years,
we've made radical improvements
to the operating system.  To
help users be able to get more
out of the device in terms of
performance and for the battery
to last longer.
There's major
improvements with the latest
version of Android covered in
the keynote today.  Can you
learn a lot more about that on
Thursday at this session here.
Boytech helped with you
improving your
profilers but there's a bunch of
other tools to improve even if
you're using another ID to build
example of your game.
Firebase offers many tools to
help you be able to track the
performance of your
application, crash analytics and
Firebase performance monitoring.
We encourage you to use those
STKs if you want to be able to
do custom logging of your issues
that you might be having with
your application.  Note, there
will be a difference in the data
that's collected from the
Firebase STK versus what's
collected true Android Vitals
which is from users who have
opted into sharing the data with
Google and our partners.
You want to learn more about
Firebase performance monitoring
and crash
analytics, you can attend this
talk at 11:30 tomorrow.  We
covered a lot in terms of what's
available in Android Vitals in
the Play Console today, but
there's a lot more today, and
you can hear all about that on
developers.Android.com/Vitals.
Just to quickly recap, we
started by covering why
performance is vital overall,
and hopefully, you all agree
that it is.
That's why you're here today so
thank you.  Then we covered
what's new in Vitals and I hope
you take advantage of these new
tools.
The then we talked about how you
can debug these Vitals issues
and finally what's available.
We'd love to be able to hear
your feedback on this talk if
you can go to this URL, provide
this feedback, we'd love to hear
from you.  If you have any
questions for us, you
can meet us from 4:00 to 5:00 at
this stand.  It's on the other
side of the lot, and
we'll also be available at the
Google Play Console sandbox from
2:00 PM to 5:00 PM tomorrow to
answer any of your questions.
Thank you all very much for
joining us here today.
We --
(applause)
Yeah.
We hope that you'll make radical
improvements to your application
over the next year and that
you'll get covered in our IO
talk over the next year.  So
best of luck to you all with
improving your application.
Thank you.
(Session was concluded at 5:40
PM CT)
***
This text, document, or file is
based on live transcription.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART), captioning,
and/or live transcription are
provided in order to facilitate
communication
accessibility and may not be a
totally verbatim record of the
proceedings.  This text,
document, or file is not to be
distributed or used in any way
that may violate copyright law.
***